on
un homme politique français en prison le
maire de tous les vices président du
conseil général de meurthe-et-moselle
inculpé dans une affaire de fausses
factures et de corruption diot sur une
île des antilles pour monsieur
mitterrand et bush le président de la
communauté européenne se fait expliquer
par le chef d'état américain les
intentions des états unis en europe
comment transformer une banale
destruction en un spectacle son et
lumière si tout va bien c'est ce que
vous pourrez suivre en direct dans ce
journal
implosion de deux tours hlm des années
soixante à trappes à 20h19 précis des
médecins israéliens mettent au point un
détecteur de cancer qui permet pour de
nombreux types de cette maladie avec une
marge d'erreur minimum de l'éviter kt et
en moins d'une madame monsieur bonsoir
politique et affairisme un voisinage
dangereux qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
mais qui régulièrement se rappelle cette
fois ci une semaine après que les
députés est adopté une loi d'aministie
sur toutes les affaires de financement
politique
un juge d'instruction vient d'inculper
et des crocs et un homme politique
monsieur jacques gosso maire rpr de toul
et vice président du conseil général de
meurthe et moselle cinq chefs
d'inculpation sont retenus contre lui
tel que faux et usage de faux corruption
une affaire de fausses factures qui
remonte déjà un certain temps et qui met
en cause de nombreuses personnalités de
la région à l'occasion de l'implantation
de grandes surfaces
moyennant financement secret bien
entendu hervé brusini ne parlez surtout
pas d'amnistié ou juge-t-il
vous ne mettriez en colère et fausses
factures c'est un peu ça bataille sagaie
hier soir pendant quatre heures et demie
le feu roulant ces questions n'avaient
qu'un objectif faire la vérité sur le
rôle exact joué par le maire de toul
jacques gosso et l'homme a tout reconnu
l'enrichissement personnel la corruption
le financement de son parti le rpr il
est vrai qu'un entrepreneur de toul
sympathisants du rpr en règle usa y
avait d'ores et déjà fourni aux juges
des pièces accablante
en fait de maçonnerie l'entreprise de
cuzorn était surtout une officine de
fausses factures un intermédiaire entre
les propriétaires de supermarchés locaux
et les élus montage était simple sykora
voulait faire construire une grande
surface
il achetait tout simplement
la décision de certains membres de cette
commission départementale d'urbanisme
commercial
elle a tout pouvoir en la question
l'argent allait à gossau qui est membre
de la commission via andré gazaille des
reconnaissances de dette fictive
prouvent les liens entre les deux hommes
en 86 dans sa mairie gosso son gîte à se
présenter à la députation un projet sans
suite
et le maire de toul s'était pourtant
déjà constitué un trésor de guerre grâce
aux subsides du grand commerce régional
ce trésor jagot se reconnaît l'avoir en
partie conservée et redistribués à
quelques responsables locaux c'est à
cause de tout cela que ce soir jacques
gosso est en prison cette affaire relève
en partie du droit commun autre
révélation de l'entrepreneur usaï
castorama serait également passer par
lui toujours dans le même but fausses
factures de plus de deux millions et
demi de francs le trésorier du rpr
aurait conseillé de passer par étapes
un bureau d'études située à paris un
dossier qui lui tombera très
certainement sous le coup de la ministre
ce soir le secrétaire général du rpr
alain juppé ne faisait guère de
commentaires
il ya une enquête judiciaire d'abord je
suis pas venu ici pour parler de ça
aujourd'hui
et j'appelle tout à fait confiance avant
4h à toul en revanche les élus
socialistes réclament un audit sur la
gestion de la ville ils veulent toute la
transparence sur la comptabilité
municipal décidément c'est une tempête
que le juge t-il a soulevé dans le même
genre à paris le syndicat force ouvrière
annonce que le trésorier de sa
fédération des employés cadres a donné
sa démission accusé d'escroquerie le
préjudice est estimé pour l'instant
environ 5 millions de francs
la grande politique maintenant la plus
petite île des antilles saint-martin
possession franco hollandaise pour une
rencontre entre le président mitterrand
et l'américain george bush au programme
l'europe de l'est et ses bouleversements
quasi quotidiens l'europe de l'ouest est
la nouvelle organisation politique que
les états unis voudraient lui voir
adopter en transformant notamment
l'alliance atlantique en une
organisation beaucoup plus politique et
en se rapprochant de la communauté
européenne il était donc intéressant que
le chef de l'état français actuellement
président de la communauté européenne en
discute avec george bush jacques à bout
ça yves barbe
un rendez vous informel à saint martin
une île caraïbe un peu hybride
hollandaise au sud le concours
présidentiel a atterri française au nord
où un hélicoptère a déposé le chef de
l'état une brève rencontre avec george
bush dans un lieu touristique
l'habitation dont le nom évoque en
créole les anciennes plantations de
canne à sucre
mais le temps des deux présidents et
comptait moins de quatre heures à passer
ensemble qu'il s'agisse de tête à tête
ou d'entretien élargi à leur suite
il comprend les ministres des affaires
étrangères ils se sont toutefois
accordés un bref moment de détente en
arpentant une plage de beau sable blanc
sous un soleil ardent
mais il n'était pas question de baignade
pour les deux présidents
nous retrouvons maintenant en direct de
saint martin jaks à bouchard pour le
compte-rendu politique de ces trois
heures d'entretien monsieur entre
monsieur boucher mitterrand qui s'est
fait donc préciser les intentions
américaines à propos du rôle que les
états unis voudraient voir jouer par
l'europe du marché commun face aux
bouleversements de l'est alors dans tout
cela
jacques bouchard yat-il place pour un
tout petit peu de détente face à cette
magnifique marina et bien cette marina
je peux vous dire que c'est un véritable
crève coeur pour george bush qui est un
fanatique de course en mer et et croyez
moi il aurait bien aimé monter sur un de
ces beaux bateaux qui sillonnent la mer
caraïbe
enfin le temps court actuellement les
deux présidents achèvent leur déjeuner
et doivent tenir tout à l'heure
peut-être même avant la fin de votre
journal une conférence de presse
ensemble devant les journalistes une
conférence de presse qui se tiendra dans
une salle
le salon amiral qui n'a jamais aussi
bien porté son nom
voilà donc pour les deux présidents
vous savez cette rencontre de saint
martin est très bref c'est vrai mais le
dialogue entre les deux hommes est
pratiquement ininterrompue ils se sont
vus à bruxelles au dernier sommet de
l'otan a en juillet george bush était à
paris pour le sommet de l'arche et au
printemps c'est françois mitterrand qui
avait été reçue dans la propriété
familiale débouche aux états unis donc
pour les deux prisons de quoi s'agit-il
bien il s'agit de faire un suivi des
dossiers de les mettre à jour
ils ont l'un et l'autre vu récemment
michael gorbatchev à kiev
et hamas et depuis les soviétiques ont
lancé une nouvelle offre spectaculaire
le retrait une proposition de retrait de
toutes leurs forces
six cent mille hommes des pays de l'est
européen avant de l'en la fin de ce
millénaire
donc voilà un thème qui s'imposent
aujourd'hui cette rencontre des deux
présidents alors que du côté américain
on agite en ce moment trois idées
premier rider les états unis veulent et
doivent rester présent en europe
deuxième idée bravo pour les
transformations à l'est mais attention
n'allons pas trop vite car alors on
risquerait un retour de bâton est la
principale victime serait monsieur
gorbatchev
troisième idée les etats unis
considèrent que la communauté des
dosettes une formidable locomotive dans
la nouvelle europe qui se construit ils
l'ont dit ils veulent s'y arrimer ces
propositions été précisé en début de
semaine à berlin par monsieur baker du
côté français il faut le dire on a réagi
sans beaucoup d' enthousiasme avec même
une certaine réserve police
merci jacques on se retrouve donc tout à
l'heure éventuellement pour le début de
la conférence de presse commune vous
avez vu la salle entre messieurs
mitterrand et georges bush les rencontre
au sommet entre les principaux chefs
d'état du monde se multiplient donc en
ce moment il faut dire que les
événements les deux ans en permanence
aujourd'hui encore en allemagne de l'est
vient le parti communiste est réunie est
longue c'est pas ce qui sortira de cette
réunion peut-être un sabordage général
peut être un changement de nom pour le
parti en tout cas une remise en cause
évidente pour la première fois des
dissidents également pris la parole
aujourd'hui
et l'on s'est aussi interrogé sur l'idée
donc lancé à moscou de retirer toutes
les troupes soviétiques stationnés dans
les pays de l'est
hier encore satellite direct de l'urss
berlin-est philippe rochot
c'est par la presse de l'armée populaire
est allemande a appris que les
soviétiques allait retirer leurs forces
de toute l'europe de l'est
c'était à l'ouverture de la deuxième
séance du congrès du parti communiste
les militaires et allemands savent ainsi
qu'ils ne pourront plus compter sur la
présence des trois cent cinquante mille
soldats soviétiques stationné en rda
nous avons fait l'avenir dépend de
l'attitude des deux états allemands en
allemagne fédérale
il y a aussi des troupes de l'otan cissé
trouve se retire aussi les deux
allemagnes pourront très bien assurer
elles mêmes leur propre sécurité
berlin appuyé cette position du retrait
des forces soviétiques et de l'otan la
france a aussi son contingent en
allemagne fédérale 2 octobre bien des
endroits comme kenzo - drogba quand
l'iphone louvre me down under
par exemple pendant la visite de
mitterrand en rda la france doit faire
un geste de bonne volonté quand les
militaires évoquent à la tribune la
réunification allemande dont savent
aussi qu'elles supposent une seule armée
pour un seul peuple
mais dans le cadre de l'europe
et là dedans démocrate une europe et
dans les pays livrons dans une maison
commune européenne démocratique il n'y
aura plus besoin de présence militaire
mais il ne pourra pas y avoir de maison
commune européenne ces montants que sera
maintenu une concentration militaire
aussi forte
des deux côtés ce modèle
le parti communiste est allemand estime
officiellement que la réunification
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour mais il sait
aussi qu'un retrait soviétique de rda va
en accéléré le processus
elle est encore le chancelier kohl
chancelier d'allemagne fédérale en
visite en hongrie plaide une nouvelle
fois pour une allemagne unis dans le
cadre d'une europe également unis dit il
et puis en yougoslavie
le parti communiste prendre les libertés
politiques et fait savoir qu'il voudrait
bien voir son pays adhérer à la
communauté europe et comme toujours dans
des périodes de grands bouleversements
la grande histoire côtoie la petite en
allemagne de l'est l'une des
conséquences de cette récente liberté
retrouvée symbolisée par l'émigration à
l'ouest on croit avoir tout dit ou
presque sur ces événements puis
lanceront la volonté de faire
connaissance avec un nouveau monde n'est
pas toujours exemple de cruauté ainsi
pour la seule ville de berlin est les
autorités ont recensé une centaine
d'enfants abandonnés par leurs parents
qui sont passés à l'ouest en quête de
philippe rochot dénis à 4 ans il fait
partie avec son petit frère stefan des
enfants pour qui l'ouverture des
frontières de la rda aura signifié la
fin de la vie de famille
la fuite à l'ouest des parents qui les
ont abandonnés
déni et stefan vivaient avec leur mère
dans cette avenue de berlin est au
deuxième étage
le matin du 10 novembre au lendemain de
l'ouverture du mur de berlin
leur mère a pris son petit déjeuner avec
eux puis elle est passée à l'ouest pour
ne pas revenir
les voisins ont donné l'alerté la police
est venue les chercher des nids et
stefan se retrouve à présent dans un
home d'enfants aux côtés d'autres
garçons et filles est qui eux ont encore
leurs parents reçoivent des visites et
rentrer à la maison pour les vacances
il parle peu et ne pousse jamais de
questions sur leurs parents stéphane
accuse un certain retard mental et les
éducateurs se demande si ce n'est pas
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles leur
mère les a abandonnés dans un pays où
l'enfant est facilement pris en charge
par l'état
ils seront bien entendu suivi mais
stefan et denis resteront marqués
psychologiquement c'est une cassure qui
se ressentira plus tard leur vie ici
n'est pas trop mauvaise car ils sont
chez nous leurs journées sont réglés ce
qui n'était pas le cas dans leur famille
mais bien sûr ils n'ont jamais de visite
et malgré nos appels personne ne s'est
présenté pour les prendre en charge
stéphane et dennis ne peuvent pas être
adoptés car il faudrait que les parents
renonce à la garde des enfants
sans cette bande un communes sont dans
le même cas berlin-est abandonnés par
leurs parents qui sont passés à l'ouest
ce sont eux qui payent
ici le prix de la liberté pour tous en
france maintenant un récent rapport
s'interrogeait sur le revenu minimum
d'insertion le rmi qui existe depuis un
an maintenant distribuée aux chômeurs en
fin de droits un budget de 6 milliards
de francs près de 500 mille
bénéficiaires une moyenne de 1600 francs
par personne payée par l'état la
question posée est la suivante
ce revenu minimum permettait justement
comme son nom l'indiqué la réinsertion
dans le monde du travail assez peu
finalement exemple pourtant choisi dans
un des départements les plus actifs dans
ce domaine le tarn et garonne à
montauban précisément reporter jean
payebien jicquel depuis une semaine
christian participent à la rénovation
d'un
une activité qui met fin à lui mois de
chômage à toulouse l'association village
82 qui assure ce chantier emploie
quelques stagiaires et rémy en insertion
comme christian il perçoit 3000 francs
le rmi plus une aide du département
je suis revenu sur montagne mais que mon
frère il m'a dit bon t'as qu'à venir à
moi j'étais bien je vais là tu as dit
que tu trouve du travail et vous trouvez
que vous êtes suffisamment rémunéré pour
ce que vous faites pas un choix mais je
voudrais 2000 a failli quand même la
société hlm du tarn et garonne emplois
de stagiaires qui ont signé pour six
mois un contrat de retour à l'emploi
sorte de super et rémy pour le nettoyage
des parties communes
brigitte touche 3700 francs par mois son
contrat s'achève
il faut trouver autre chose et c'est
tout autre chose encore
si certains prennent le stage comme
palliatif au chômage d'autres sont plus
exigeants ainsi philippe l'assistante
sociale lui a trouvé un stage au service
d'urbanisme
après ça mois de recherche ici 50 % des
bénéficiaires du rmi ont accepté un
contrat d'insertion deux fois plus que
la moyenne nationale
pourtant on ne pavoise pas ils restent
tous ceux qui refusent ce qu'ils vont
nous refusez ça va poser un problème de
fond d'ici quelque temps c'est que la
loi prévoit effectivement que
l'insertion entre guillemets est la
contrepartie si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
du paiement de la location
et là il appartiendra aux autorités
préfectorales de prendre une décision
quant au maintien ou pas du versement de
l'allocation
le préfet peut renouveler la location
même sans stage mais l'insertion reste
l'objectif en sur cent mille contrats en
france 4000 seulement au permis aux
bénéficiaires de retrouver un emploi
il reste beaucoup à faire pour atteindre
l'objectif la lutte contre la drogue en
colombie la guerre contre les
trafiquants se poursuit l'un des
principaux chefs du cartel de medellin a
été abattu aujourd'hui par la police au
cours d'un affrontement dans lequel 15
de ses gardes du corps ont également été
tués un gainsbourg
une petite erreur là d'aiguillage on va
voir maintenant le sujet sur la colle en
doublon est l'événement de ce jour à
savoir ce trafiquant de drogue mexicains
43 ans classée en tête sur les listes
noires de tous les services secrets et
bureau anti drogue colombiens et
américains gonzalo rodriguez gatcha qui
j'ai par la police dans une hacienda
d'être elias au nord-ouest du pays
une propriété qui appartiendrait au
cerveau du cartel de medellin pablo
escobar actuellement en fuite gatcha
ennemi public numéro un en colombie a
battu avec son fils et 15 de leurs
gardes après une longue traque
voilà qui prouve que les barons de la
drogue ne sont pas invincibles ils sont
aux abois et tomberont tôt ou tard gatx
à tomber sur renseignements gatcha trahi
lui qui se vantait d'être aussi
populaire lui l'homme généreux qui
offraient des centaines de dollars aux
paysans pauvres mais des dollars grâce
auquel ils finançaient aussi des
organisations paramilitaires impliquées
dans des attentats
gatx à la terreur et son armée de 1000
hommes et tueur à gages stimuler dans
des centres d'entraînement ou le
mexicain régnait en maître
le gouvernement colombien avait mis sa
capture a pris deux cent cinquante mille
dollars
les autorités harcelés en guerre contre
cette mafia de la drogue qui ne recule
devant rien elle l'a prouvé une fois de
plus le 6 décembre dernier en faisant
sauter le quartier général de la police
secrète à bogota 64 morts 500 blessés
les terroristes auraient agi sur ordre
de gatcha aujourd'hui la mort de l'homme
durs du cartel porte un coup sévère à la
mafia la cocaïne avec lui disparaît
aussi son fils à 17 ans freddy
s'apprêtait à prendre la relève
comment transformer un événement banal
en véritable événement véritable
spectacle il fallait y penser c'est ce
qu'ont fait les responsables de la
municipalité de trappes dans la grande
banlieue parisienne ce soir ils vont
détruire en les faisant imploser deux
tours d'un quartier qui va être
prochainement réhabiliter l'événement va
avoir lieu dans quelques minutes en
direct sous vos yeux l'implosion de ces
constructions sous forme de spectacle
son et lumière la présentation d'abord
gens paisibles qui je suis
le fantôme de l'immeuble
c'est par un spectacle que trappe ce
soir salue la pl aux ions de 160
logements hlm comme la courneuve la
société nationale de démolition a
travaillé deux mois pour affaiblir les
murs avant de placer les explosifs qui
feront sa fessée les tour sur elle-même
en deux ans on aura ainsi démoli sur le
quartier 400 logements ça ira mieux
quand on a eu le disent on est la tour
eiffel la bastille bon ben aujourd'hui
on rattrape
c'est une super fête mais je suis très
content et fier fier très fier
dégradation concentrations trop fortes
d'immigrés jusqu'à 50% sur le quartier
dans une ville frappée par le chômage
ce sont les raisons données par les
responsables de trappes pour ces
démolitions
elles ont lieu dans le cadre de la
réhabilitation générale du quartier 2500
logements même bien loger certains
locataires des tours accepte mal la
démolition fait de savoir que ce soir
les immeubles plutôt l immeuble que j'ai
habité pendant tant d'années n'existera
plus me cause ou non ce n'est pas pour
nous détecteurs pour nous des prisons
ces logements mais un moment donné si
nous voulons que la population
trappistes et des habitants de tra
puissent vivre dignement comme et chaque
citoyen dans une ville d'agde il est
indispensable de prendre ces mesures
à la place des tours trappe veut faire
un nouvel urbanisme avec des maisons et
de petits immeubles ainsi que des
équipements publics qui manquent d'eau
d'un commissariat
le but réinsérer ce quartier dans la
ville voilà on retrouve ainsi en direct
jean pellieux alors j'en paye eux c'est
leur ou non oui je vous reçois assez
faiblement nous sommes ici à trappes sur
le quartier des merisiers à une
trentaine de kilomètres de paris
et c'est juste derrière nous vous le
voyez ce je pense en ce moment que se
situent ces deux tours qui vont applause
et dans quelques minutes
je suis ici en avec le maire bernard
hugo lemaire
trappes votre sentiment vous pour en
finir avec des ghettos comme celui que
nous allons détruire dans quelques
instants il faut que toutes les communes
importantes de france construire du
logement social de qualité avec des
crédits de crédit véritable une aide
véritable de l'êta vient vous savez que
160 logements vont tomber un peu près
huit secondes c'est un procédé qui a
maintenant parfaitement au point et qui
a été montré en particulier sur notre
antenne à la courneuve
alors ici se déroule derrière nous donc
ce spectacle audiovisuel feux d'artifice
lasers on raconte en ce moment
l'histoire de ces immeubles qui ne date
que je dirais de 20 ans et vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui c'est donc devenu je
dirais pas une mode mais en tout cas une
pratique assez commune que l'on fasse
exploser ou imploser
c'est tours hlm des quartiers un petit
peu déshérités avec un spectacle autour
je dirais un spectacle où il fait comme
pour exorciser en quelque sorte le passé
je vous laisse un instant regard des
spectacles je pense que nous approchons
maintenant de du moment où vont
précisément étonné les instructions pour
l'explosion
pour l'été
aïe
qui
tout va bien
et responsable aux quelques instants de
retard par rapport au planning qui
avaient été fixés jeu j'écoute car nous
allons en principe entendre des cornes
de brume qui devrait annoncer le dernier
voyage de ce bateau symbolique
symbolique à cause de cette autour et
voilà je pense maintenant la la fin de
de ce spectacle attention
raciste une baisse un peu
je finis mon histoire dans deux minutes
je vais partir je ne sais pas je te
dirai tout à l'heure maintenant il faut
que tu partes
il est temps de se dire aurevoir va va
vite
ma petite fille petite vie oui
où es tu maintenant avec tout le monde
au milieu de la foule bien
regarde c'est au tour des habitants de
quitter l'immeuble tous ceux qui y ont
habité là depuis 15 ans et qui ont
laissé les traces de leur passage leur
mémoire ou leur esprit ils s'en vont
aussi regardent
au revoir petites filles en bas le
bateau va faire son dernier voyage
de brume dans une vingtaine de secondes
un peu clair il veut abonnement orange
est sous vos yeux
non heureusement
ok et la partie
voilà on a attendu un peu mais on l'a vu
le jeu revient à la politique maintenant
avec cet après-midi un tir groupé contre
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste monsieur mauroy jacques
delors d'abord qui affirme que le ps est
minée par le nombrilisme
c'est ce qu'il a dit est que ces
divisions et bien ruineront les espoirs
des français dans la gauche ajoutant le
ps n'existe pas à l'extérieur de la
france depuis que monsieur jospin n'en
n'est plus le premier secrétaire et puis
les amis de monsieur chevènement qui
affirme aussi que les positions de
monsieur moreau en faveur d'une
réduction des moyens de défense de la
france sont irresponsables je lis un
après midi de chien pour le ministre de
la santé claude evin venu à saint
nazaire posé la première pierre d'un
centre hospitalier il a été accroché par
150 médecins et membres de professions
paramédicales en colère en lui
reprochant principalement le nouveau
projet de convention médicale spécifique
aux généralistes à l'un de mes skis les
ex carabins face aux carabiniers
monsieur et 20 le ministre de la santé
est là pour poser la première pierre
d'un nouveau bâtiment à saint nazaire la
profession il a également travaux
pratiques de traumatologie et plusieurs
médecins seront aux urgences pour se
faire soigner
150 médecins et membres de professions
paramédicales reproche au ministre très
vivement comme on le voit les nouvelles
orientations de la politique de santé en
particulier le projet de loi qui
permettrait la signature de deux
conventions une pour les généralistes
une pour les spécialistes en quittant
les lieux
le ministre a regretté que certains
aient choisi la violence plutôt que le
dialogue ait réaffirmé qu'il n'était pas
question de reculer le cinéma vient de
perdre l'une des grandes actrices
italiennes révélé dans les années 50
silvana mangano vient de mourir à madrid
d'une tumeur cancéreuse à l'âge de 59
ans son premier succès qui on cache à
beaucoup d'autres fut son apparition
dans riz amer c'était en 1949 un
physique superbe que l'on remarqua plus
à l'époque que son interprétation de
faut bien le dire et lui cependant
l'occasion de changer de gens dans mort
à venise par exemple nicole corneilhan
doigts
ennemi comme istres homme quand cette
danse à 19 ans en 1949 provoque un
succès international
tous les spectateurs ont alors pour elle
le regardera vallone de vittorio gassman
impudique volcanique érotique
elles dépassent largement les espérances
du réalisateur néo réaliste de santis
mais là mangane on veut proclamer au
monde que ces superbes puis ce ne sont
pas ses seuls atouts et le prouve en
tournant avec les plus grands
réalisateurs américains comme martin
richard fleischer mais surtout italiens
comme de sica comencini bologne et les
sorcières pour l'infernal pas nue et
devient aristocrate pour visconti
comtesse polonaise dans mort à venise
mr ambiguë du jeune talent zoo elle
donne une image d'élégance d'équilibré
et de distinctions une image qu'elle a
conservé tout au long de sa vie épouse
de dino de laurentiis mère de trois
filles et d'un fils disparu elle est
restée digne et discrète jusqu'au bout
du voyage le sport maintenant avec le
tennis et la finale de la coupe davis
entre la suède et l'allemagne fédérale
ce soir et bien au terme du double la
rfa mène 2 à 1 contre la suède olivier
rey
l'allemagne de l'ouest a pris une option
sur la victoire finale en coupe davis
grâce à boris becker et ridge hélène qui
ont marqué en effet un point très
important en remportant le double face
au suédois jarry dur darson en cinq sets
7 6 6 4 3 6 6 7 et 6 4
après avoir enlevé les deux premiers
sets le double allemand a subi la loi
des suédois qui sont revenus à égalité
deux sets partout dans le cinquième set
grâce à la puissance de boris becker
l'allemagne s'est imposée et mène donc 2
victoires à une
tout se jouera lors du dernier match
très certainement entre boris becker et
max wilander grâce à becker vainqueur
cette année de wimbledon et de l'us open
l'allemagne de l'ouest est bien parti
pour conserver la coupe désiste qu'elle
a conquis l'an passé face à ces mêmes
suédois voilà pour terminer maintenant
les rapports du tiercé du quarté + qui
se courre est aujourd'hui voici les
résultats du tiercé un peu plus de 7000
francs et puis pour ce qui concerne le
kart et bien vous ajoutez le 3 et vous
gagnez un peu plus de 96 mille francs
voilà ce journal est terminée avec un
petit peu de retard et une implosion
retarder ce qui nous empêchait de
diffuser le reportage prévu et promis
dans les titres sur ce détecteur de
cancer découvert et mise au point par
des chercheurs israéliens mais je vous
promets nous essaierons de vous passer
dès demain
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après la météo philippe gas aux
alentours de 23 heures 35 bonne soirée
sur notre chaîne bonsoir à demain 13
non